earlier today one of the students inside
the school when the shooting actually
started her name is Megan he'll listen
to her describe this heroine scene I was
sitting in class the bottom floor the
freshman building and all we heard was
gunshots heard 15 rounds shoot the
ceiling we all dope to the left side
where the windows were our teacher told
us to get to the side but like closest
to the door so we all ran behind the
desk the shooter the good thing the door
was locked this shooter shot through the
door poked in shot a couple people next
to me I was sitting right behind a
cabinet and the bullet pass that your
got a girl next to me we couldn't help
anybody and the time because we had to
say quiet 911 wasn't working on my phone
apparently the guy got out there's dead
bodies in the hallway people were killed
in the hallway
my sister was running she's in the
bathroom in time and she ran from him
and got luckily to room that she found
open on the phone right now is that
student that you just heard from Megan
Hill Megan thank you for taking the time
to join us you're a junior as I
understand it you're in a room this door
is locked
this guy's shooting take it from there
what happened from there Megan um as the
shooter was in the hallway I'm not sure
if I was the first room he stopped
through the glass windows did not open
our doors and he turned the gun towards
the side of the wall where the students
were sitting he thought four people one
was dead there are three other injured a
girl was caught in her ribs a girl a
bullet clip the top of her kneecap I was
pulled the stake home all I wanted to do
was help but I knew it but everybody
else life in jeopardy after ten minutes
I finally couldn't stand any more I took
off my jean jacket I threw it over the
desk and had someone tried to help the
girl front of me I'm not sure to hold
that the exact hit but I find my hardest
everyone's trying to stay calm
I finally got a hold of my sister
McKenzie he was in the second floor
bathroom got into a door safely and the
t-shirt they're not allowed to open the
doors for a policy on CodeRed but you
luckily then stay thirsty was put in
suit room and survived and it was very
common sizing you were told to leave the
building they told us of one out left
head
in one Street the fine island there were
bodies on the floor not stirred that or
not near the folder run yeah and here's
my sister Mackenzie
Megan I go ahead and Megan hi this is
mr. Mackenzie Hill and first of all I
want to say I'm really sorry for all
these victims in this family
and there's a Chinese as you can do it
no loss of words don't soften this you
know Megan so so all of a sudden you're
a lot you adore your classroom is locked
or so make sure I'm hearing you well and
the shooter little shoots through the
door then sticks has gone into the
classroom four people get shot right in
front of you one person you believe is
it died who's instantly killed you're
trying to help a friend of yours and
pass over your jean jacket and
everyone's telling you no no stop stay
still be quiet
and what happens from that point I
didn't fully understand from that point
on the and about a couple minutes seaman
bangs on our doors leads us down they
came in they asked who was hurt
we told the four people that were hurt
they got them out of the room and they
escorted us just like I said before we
turn left and headed straight the point
I wonder yeah you know and then about
ten minutes go by
in the interim 10-minute period after
the did he stays shooting long how long
was he actually shooting into the
classroom he was shooting in the
classroom no longer than a couple
seconds he was shooting in the hallway
up at the ceiling and dust was falling
on to us then he stopped through the
glass window and turned his guns to the
right and we thought a couple people
yeah and so and then I guess you heard a
loud bang and that was the police coming
to rescue all of you yes there was going
to make sure we were okay clear up the
room you know I I can't even imagine
what it would what it had to be like for
you and you had your twin sister who was
on the floor above you in the bathroom
well I he was actually in that class
with me it's ap psychology
five minutes before the shooting
actually happened - you asked to see Sir
to go to the restroom the restroom on
the first floor was lost so she went up
to the second floor in the second floor
she heard gunshots
she was with a friend and do you left
the bathroom and he saw the shooter but
going to ask last name just in time for
them the letter in the room I understand
your sister is there as she was in the
second-floor bathroom I don't know if
Mackenzie can hear me but maquette
Mackenzie you had an experience that you
went up to the bathroom you both I guess
or an AP psych and there is a freshman
girl that had severe asthma and take it
from there and all the teachers had
locked the door and you guys are running
literally door to door and and this poor
girl is obviously struggling right I ran
I was falling I got ladies next to me
and I ran to the nearest bathroom I went
through the door and the teacher in the
classroom other school policies they
would not let me in because of this
policy here in my face and let me inside
the classroom I feel that if the teacher
knows and has done that he can let you
in the classroom and school shootings in
a scenario like I was in than he should
do it because it's faster to not let me
in I could have think so today and I'm
very grateful for this teacher
yeah when I go on the classroom she said
well since arresting me along with all
the other students we sit in the back of
the room hearing all these thoughts
around us and everyone's trying to
immediately I called texting my sister
he was faster than the first board not
knowing anything if she does not respond
and I cannot bear the fact that losing
my best friend I'm fine his banana king
or I'm here that four people shot in
your classroom you know her nothing else
I do not know if he's okay yeah you know
I want to say this to both you and your
sister Megan
both of you showed amazing courage today
Megan trying to to help the girl next to
her and and you obviously helping this
poor girl that that had this asthma
attack as she's going on there trying to
calm her down my best as I can do
if you should call them and I'll make it
work yeah and when did you actually
reunite because how long after was it
that you were able to find your sister
again
well after I thought of the building she
told me that she thought out an hour
before me because she was already down
the street waiting for me and I do not
know she's okay because I do not have
contact with her because I'm still in my
classroom and I was supposed to bounce
my cell phone so I thought oh I finally
see her and I didn't walk up the
building I'm seeing blood and people
wounded everywhere and I see my security
guards and it just broke my heart seeing
all these poor people wounded and I
couldn't bear the fact that someone who
come to this school and she does summon
Douglas I just it was like a dream to me
like I'm gonna seems like I couldn't
believe it I'm still in shock just like
right now yeah I I can't imagine how
hard this is for both of you both of you
showed amazing courage today under the
most difficult circumstances
no no child should have to see that ever
Meagan Mackenzie thank you both we wish
you and your families and and your your
friends obviously you're gonna have a
very tough week ahead as these families
are now struggling in the school is
struggling in this community this is a
very tight-knit community down in
parkland to come to grips with this this
horrible evil shooting today